good morning Hank it's Tuesday are
probably the two consecutive sentences I
have spoken most often in my life it's
either that or I love you let's get some
pizza which you know I said to mom when
I was 4 and I said to Henry and the Yeti
now anyway it's Tuesday unless you're me
in which case it's actually Saturday
morning
it's Saturday because later this morning
the Yeti and Henry and I are going on
vacation and on Tuesday I will be on
that vacation without a computer that's
right Hank for the first time since I
got this computer it's going to spend a
night without me it's ok Shh Willie's
got to stay - you're gonna be fine mmm
you're ok it's ok I know I know
make the reason we're leaving behind
computers on this vacation is that I
think sometimes it's good to reset your
brain not to expect like a new celebrity
pregnancy every day and more generally
Hank I'm a little worried that I've
become addicted to the internet like I
remember the end of 2006 and we were
talking about starting brother - 2.0
Sara said to me I don't understand how
you're gonna do this because you already
spent so much time on the internet and I
was like no no no no making videos is
gonna replace my internet time like the
time that I now spend falling down the
rabbit hole of the Internet I'm going to
spend making and editing videos I mean
that wasn't even any Twitter Tumblr what
did I do on the Internet in 2006 Google
the weather in Dubai but anyway Hank in
the manner of an addict I convinced
myself that starting an online video
project would decrease the amount of
time I spent online yeah no I think I
don't want the Internet to be confused
about my feelings I love the Internet
like yesterday Henry and I spent 20
minutes on the Wikipedia article for
whale sharks because we had a
disagreement about whether whale sharks
bite humans I don't want to brag but I
was right and toward all that stuff
about whale sharks cost us nothing I
also think that the community and
connection I feel because of the
Internet has made my life richer and
better however I am looking forward to
doing a lot of reading this week without
every four minutes a little part of my
brain being like have you checked your
email there might be something important
something with that said I now venture
into a brave new world where human
beings talk to each other in real life
and breathe on each other
touch occasional it just sounds really
germy but I'm gonna do it because I
think it's good for my mental health
particularly in advance of Carnegie Howe
which is the sound that my anxiety makes
and thinking of Carnegie Hall
nerdfighters if you don't have tickets
to Carnegie Hall I have great news there
is a link in the doobly-doo where there
are hundreds of places around the
country and around the
world where you can gather together to
watch a live stream of the Carnegie Hall
event so go to that link and find one
and then go to a nerdfighter gotta meet
new nerdfighters etc and last think I'm
really sorry if something terrible or
excellent happened in the last like
three days that I don't know about and
everyone's like why isn't he talking
about this in his video it's because I
am in the past Hank thank you for the 53
wonderful terrible jokes don't forget to
be awesome I will see you on Saturday
everyone else will see you on Friday but
I get back on Saturday I'll see you then